wie war basel möchte wissen kriegt ihr
geld für eure seite wenn ja wie viel
über geld spricht man nicht
wie kriege ich schon ein bisschen
weshalb wie gesagt ein gutes taschengeld
können davon einige sagt finanzieren
auch zwischendurch mal klamotten oder
feiern gehen und so halten hat man halt
für unter brüdern auf alter angepasst da
fragt raubtier cannabis nein eigentlich
nicht
nicht wie viel kitsch es knallt ihr leon
fragt hans zweck ja hans weg das ist
bisher privat habe es läuft auf jeden
fall formuliert also wären auf jeden
fall viele nette jungen frauen kennen
auch da in unserer seite das auch
ziemlich verwunderlich ist für mich
immer wieder aber und einen fall zu
beantworten
genug um alles oder nichts
möchte wissen seid ihr alle schwarz
doch doch halte man sieht oder halb
dieser hat mir geschrieben maximal warum
sie schwarz sind
aber nicht jeder hat das glück mit toren
fragt wie reagiert er gegenüber einem
rassisten
das kommt immer ganz darauf an also wenn
jetzt beispielsweise irgendjemanden
bilden kommentar bei uns hinterlässt
dann wird der entweder ignoriert oder
wenn man gerade bisschen schlecht drauf
sein fach geblockt und ansonsten wenn
das auf der straße vorkommt oder das ist
wirklich einmal situationsbezogen ich
können uns jetzt hier als engel preisen
und so dass wir uns immer ganz die ruhe
bewahren und so weiter und so fort das
passiert natürlich nicht immer aber wir
schaffen es mittlerweile eigentlich ganz
gut damit umzugehen und können
eigentlich alles und jegliche
situationen ein bisschen humor lösen und
schaffen wir schon auf jeden fall
man fragt seid ihr rassisten
nein also gar keine rassisten weil wir
sind auch halt ziemlich gemixt
aufgewachsen von deutsch türken und
kurden sind halt in unserem freund ist
also auch in unserem engen freundeskreis
freundeskreis also auch in unserem
freundeskreis freundeskreis deswegen
wäre schwierig zu sein
wollt ihr euch einen auf eurer likes
nein nicht